hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast Micro Wars the rise of
CRISPR immunity and technology presented
by dr. Megan hawk Strasser science
communications manager innovative
genomics Institute we are excited to
bring you this educational webcast
presented by labrys the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning find Julie simmer AHS of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want but anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
then type your question into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located on the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits please join me
in welcoming dr. Megan Hawk stresser I
will now turn the presentation over to
her
great well thanks for the introduction
I'll just introduce myself again I'm
Megan hawk Strasser I got my PhD with
Jennifer Doudna at UC Berkeley and I now
manage scientific communications and
outreach basically for the innovative
genomics Institute and just to give a
little bit of background the IGI is a
group that is formed through a
partnership between UC Berkeley and UC
San Francisco and it's basically been
made so that we can advance gene editing
and other genome manipulation
technologies to the point that we can
then apply them in really crucial areas
like biomedicine and agriculture and so
today I'm going to talk to you about how
those technologies that we use every day
or have actually arisen and will tell
you a little bit about how microbes
specifically bacteria and archaea the
prokaryotes have had this war ongoing
with bacteria phage for a really long
time and how this conflict has ended up
generating a lot of really useful tools
so my talk is called the microbe Wars
the rise of CRISPR immunity and
technology so this picture right here is
basically the crux of this struggle and
this this interaction that you're seeing
right here is what has given us all the
tools that I'm going to talk about today
so what you're seeing is the sillas
shaped bacterium under attack by all
these little lollipop looking bacteria
phage so a bacteria phage is just a
virus that infects bacteria and you can
see here that there's a lot of bacteria
phage compared to this one cell from the
bacterium and so this is clearly a
threatening situation for the microbe
and so what happens is that these
bacteria phage land on the surface of
the cell and try to inject their genome
into the cell and if it's able to get in
and replicate then it makes the bacteria
phage makes more copies of itself and
then as you can see here they burst out
of the cell they lyse the cell and
destroy it and then they can go on to
infect other cells and keep spreading
that way
and so you can imagine that these cells
would be under pretty immense
evolutionary pressure to find ways to
overcome this challenge all these
bacteriophage that they're constantly
interacting with and that struggle has
is what's giving us all these different
interesting systems to study and to
co-opt for various purposes and so I'm
gonna just show you here a little review
of different ways that bacteria have
evolved to resist infection so you can
see a couple of them here so these are
all innate systems that aren't really
specific to the type of phage that's
trying to infect they're just general
defenses with bacteria always have up up
and running um so you can see ads or
absorption block adsorption block this
tries to prevent the phage from even
landing on the cell and sticking uptake
block blocks the phage DNA from coming
into the cell a board of infection is
basically a a noble suicide where the
bacterium kills itself so that it can't
be the host that the phage replicate
inside to save the other bacteria in the
area and then an interesting one here
restriction modification systems or RM
systems this is sort of one of the
better known examples of where the
struggle between bacteria and bacteria
phage has yielded a really important
biotechnology or molecular biology tool
so most scientists that have done
cloning before have used restriction
enzymes and these are enzymes that the
bacterium has that recognized really
specific DNA sequences kind of in the
hope that that sequence might appear in
the foreign phage DNA that gets injected
and so that the enzyme can cut that DNA
and prevent the infection and you can
see in this diagram the host DNA
actually has these methylated areas that
prevent the restriction enzymes from
cutting the host genome but anything
else that comes into the cell that's
foreign is it's a free-for-all and can
get destroyed and so people use these
all the time in cloning if you're trying
to ligate some DNA into a plasmid
backbone you can cut the plasmid at
really specific sites and insert DNA
with sticky ends or blunt ends or
you know if you're done cloning you know
what I'm talking about so it's been a
really fruitful area of research for of
other researchers to benefit so that's
an innate system also but what's really
interesting is the adaptive system
CRISPR which hadn't really been known
about until sort of the early 2000s and
so just to give you a really brief
overview I'm going to go way more in
depth for the whole talk on this but
just to show you here basically what
happens is the phage or the blue phage
that you can see on the top right inject
its genome and the CRISPR proteins are
CRISPR associated proteins cast proteins
will capture a little snippet of that
DNA and integrate it or put it inside of
the hosts genome so they'll take this
little chunk of blue DNA and put it into
the CRISPR locus where they store all
these little memories of different
infections and then this whole array
gets transcribed into RNA and then cut
up into functional units that are then
used by CRISPR enzymes to find the phage
if it infects again and destroy it and
so in this way you can actually the
bacterium will remember that it's been
infected before by certain viruses and
will be able to have a mounted defense
against them the next time they come
around yeah so I'm giving you a really
this image is a very kind of simplified
version of what this might look like but
I do want to impress upon you that
CRISPR systems are pretty complicated
and diverse so there's all these
different ways for a bacterium to defend
itself using CRISPR
and right here I'm showing you a bunch
of different subtypes basically so the
ones on the left are these so-called
class 1 systems that involve multi
subunit complex --is that carry out the
different steps and then the class 2
systems on the right have been a little
bit more useful for different
applications so far because they just
use a single protein that's able to use
an RNA to find a target nucleic acid and
cut it and so I think we know a lot
about these different systems
but you know as you can see with the
citation at the bottom right this our
understanding of how these have evolved
in the diversity that's out there is
changing rapidly so every couple years a
new version of this slide basically
comes out and it started out much
simpler than this so I think there's
still more to come and so everything I'm
telling you about today is sort of
already happened but I expect that if I
were to give this talk again in a year
we'd have a bunch more slides to include
and so I like to compare this these
different systems to flavors of ice
cream they're all a little bit different
and special in their own way but they're
accomplishing the same thing so yeah so
let's go into more depth about how
CRISPR systems work and this slide right
here is the overview that I like to use
and I'm going to be bringing this back
throughout the later slides as we go in
more depth to each step of how the
pathway works so CRISPR stands for
clustered regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats and this is
referring to the structure of the genome
where the different memories of the past
infections are stored so if you look on
this slide where it says CRISPR locus at
the top you see these black rectangles
those are repeats so this is the same
sequence occurring again and again and
again but they're not right together
right next to each other they're
actually separated by unique sequences
that are shown as different colored
spacers so each spacer derives from
foreign DNA so this is a bit of viral
DNA that's been captured and inserted
into this storage area and so sometimes
I'll call this a wall of shame or it's a
bunch of mug shots basically so these
are the known baddies to look out for
and this is how the cell remembers
what's infected it in the past and the
threats that it faces and so the first
step basically is in this process is to
generate those memories so when a phage
infects certain caste proteins will
capture bits of that DNA
and insert it into this locus in a
really controlled way and so this step
is called acquisition or integration or
adaptation that's kind of been changed a
little bit over the years I like to call
it acquisition so I'll probably keep
saying that and so after it's step one
when you've acquired foreign DNA the
next step is to start getting ready to
use the DNA you've acquired so this step
involves generating the guide RNA or the
crisper RNA so with Cassadine systems if
you heard a little bit about that you
usually call this guide RNA trna or
sgrna and I won't get too much into the
details of what those different RNAs are
and why they have different names but
for the most part I might call this
crispr RNA or CR RNA or a guide RNA um
so when I'm talking about those things
I'm kind of using them interchangeably
this just means an RNA that contains a
single spacer or a memory of a past
infection that an enzyme or complex of
enzymes is using to find that infection
infective agent again so what happens
here basically is that the CRISPR locus
that repeats spacer array gets
transcribed into a very long RNA called
the pre Kirk precursor crispr RNA and
then that really long RNA is not very
functional because it's just huge so it
gets chopped up so each spacer ends up
with just a little bit of the repeat
sequence on either side or sometimes
just on one side and that's considered
the functional mature crispr RNA or
guide RNA and so there's an enzyme or
it's a couple of different enzymes that
can do that processing sometimes
Kasich's cast five cast nine and some
other enzymes participate in different
systems but the point is that they need
to chop up this long thing into more
functional units so once you have the
mature guide RNA the next step is to use
that guide and find the invasive target
so an enzyme or complex of proteins will
take this RNA carry it around and look
for a match in DNA or sometimes are
as I'll talk about later and this
interaction works via base pairing so
just traditional watson-crick base
pairing that you learn about in basic
biology a pairs of T or u with RNA G
pairs with C and so if the RNA has a
sequence GCC then CGG in the target DNA
is complementary and those two strands
will base pair and that tells the enzyme
that it's found the target so the whole
complimentary sequence will zip up and
then the enzyme will cut and so cutting
that target up prevents the infection
from spreading because the genome can't
be used as a blueprint to make the
different pieces of the virus that need
to assemble to escape so once you've cut
the target you've succeeded as a
bacterium and you've stopped the
infection and so the last step this is
not really a step of CRISPR immunity but
I thought I would add it on here because
it's really interesting and I'm going to
talk about it a little bit later and but
this is basically a more recently
discovered way that bacteria phage have
been able to overcome CRISPR so in this
evolutionary battle between bacterium
and bacteriophage the bacteria phage
have responded to the phage sorry the
bacteria have responded to the phage by
evolving CRISPR systems and now the
bacteria phage have responded by
developing anti CRISPR systems so the
most well-studied are these tiny
proteins called anti CRISPR proteins
that stick on to the different CRISPR
proteins or CRISPR associated proteins
and stop them from working and so those
are really interesting from a biological
perspective but they've also more
recently been used actually for
applications biotechnology applications
so I'll talk about that a little bit
later sorry
so now I just want to show you a brief
animation that's just gonna summarize
what I kind of just went over and I will
note that this one was made to
specifically talk about the caste 9
protein and the type 2 or class 2
systems
and so it's a little bit specific but
the general process is basically the
same for all of these defense systems
and the other thing I'll note is that
this is a molecular animation made by
this really cool animator named Janet
iwasa who makes a lot of really cool
stuff so if you're interested in
molecular in a mission or scientific art
I would say it check her out because
she's a lot of really interesting videos
that she's made so now now maybe we can
watch the video bacteria use an adaptive
immune system called CRISPR to acquire
protection from viruses when a virus
injects its DNA into a bacterial cell
during infection a piece of the viral
DNA is integrated into the bacterial
genome its genetic program at a site
called CRISPR that includes a series of
repeated sequences that flank each
inserted piece of viral DNA this creates
a permanent genetic record of past
infections then the sequences are copied
into strands of RNA DNA's chemical
cousin and the RNA is chopped into
functional units each containing one
viral sequence plus the flanking repeat
the chopping process requires a separate
RNA called tracer RNA that together bind
to the cassadine protein a component of
CRISPR immunity to form a surveillance
complex upon finding DNA with a matching
sequence the cast nine RNA machine holds
onto the matching DNA sequence unwinds
it and cuts each strand of the DNA
double helix in bacteria the broken
viral DNA is chopped up and destroyed by
other proteins they are by halting the
infection all right great
so hopefully that video helped clarify
things I think it's nice to see things
in action and kind of imagine what this
might look like all together so now I'm
gonna go through basically step by step
showing you a little more detail about
how these work how these different steps
work and how after I've told you about
how a step works I'll tell you about how
the enzymes involved have actually been
co-opted for other purposes
okay so the first step as I told you and
space our acquisition so this is how the
cell generates an immunological memory
and what happens here is that caste
proteins work together to integrate an
adjunct of viral viral DNA into the
genome and as you see in this sort of
overview picture this is just shown as
two yellow blobs basically but in
reality it's actually this interesting
structure from formed by two caste
proteins called caste 1 & 2 and these
are interesting proteins because they're
actually the only ones that are common
in all those different CRISPR systems I
showed before so regardless of which
flavor of system you're using caste 1 &
2 are going to be there and they form
this crab-like complex where you have
two copies of the caste
2 in the middle and yellow and four
copies on the outside of the castle on
protein and so what these do is they
grab or capture pieces of foreign viral
DNA so that that's what this structure
is here you can see in pinkish red and
the foreign DNA and they serve as this
molecular ruler so it's really in this
case we're talking about the e.coli
system so most of what's been known
about acquisition so far has been in the
type 1 e e coli system and in that
system this spacer that gets captured is
almost always 32 base pairs so it's
really defined lengths and you can tell
by looking at this structure that part
of how that's defined is that that's
really what's the only size that's going
to fit in that spot in that distance
between those two proteins and so
they're able to also kind of trim back
its thought on the ends of that DNA to
make the mature form of the spacer or
the protis spacer that's going to be
integrated so then I'm just switching to
kind of a more schematic view of these
proteins grabbing foreign DNA and
highlighting the hydroxyl groups at the
ends of the DNA that are critical in
attacking the CRISPR array and getting
that
integrated so the next step is
recognition of the array so there's
actually this protein that we've only
learned about kind of recently and how
it's working here called IHF or
integration host factor so this again is
an e coli but it's thought that other
species of bacterium probably have a
comparable protein that's playing a
similar role and so what this does is it
bends the DNA around where the CRISPR
locus is and it's thought that this
distortion of the DNA is sort of priming
that DNA to be attacked so it can kind
of pop open and let the new spacer come
in and there were some really
interesting structures of this complex
that came out recently from this right
at out paper that I would urge you to
check out if you're interested but I'm
keeping them out for simplicity's sake
so the cows want to protein complex
recognizes the sequence at the junction
of the leader which is shown in blue so
this is just a sequence that happens
right before the first repeat and the
repeat itself and then casts wanted to
are able to integrate this spacer so all
of these things kind of have to be there
all these different proteins and
sequences for this to work and it's a
really interesting process that's kind
of been elucidated over the past couple
of years or so and so what is it that
we're doing here what is the ability of
these proteins that might be interesting
for applications and its site specific
DNA integration and so in the wild these
proteins are going to be capturing
foreign viral DNA but people have
co-opted this recently and some really
interesting papers from George church's
lab and they're using it instead to do
storage in DNA so storing information
and what I'm going to show you here is
actually storing photos and video which
is crazy and awesome I think this just
came out within the past month or so the
video component so the way that they've
gotten this to work is basically instead
of having a virus inject its genome and
that's where the DNA comes from the
experimenter provides DNA bits that are
already the right size to get integrated
and this can be done just by election
operation of DNA eligos ordered from a
company and so once those go in cast one
and two grab them because they're the
perfect size already the great substrate
and they integrate them into the CRISPR
locus and so what the experimenters did
here is they when you look sorry at this
pink stretch of DNA this is showing you
one spacer that's been electroporated in
or proto spacer which is what it's
called before it gets in so in this
proto spacer you have kind of a code
basically so they figured out a way to
use a code to say that every time
there's a C this is a 0 0 T 0 1 so
they've figured out a way to encode also
the spacing of these different pixels
basically within a picture and so
they've provided all the different all
egos that you need to encode this entire
picture and given those two the probe to
the bacteria that integrate them and
then they can take after that's been
integrated they can take the bacterium's
DNA and sequence it and see you know
which spacers were integrated and decode
that and formulate a picture which is
very cool and then more recently so
they've sort of done some of that before
but the more interesting maybe maybe not
more interesting but the really really
cool thing that they did with this was
to encode a gif or Jif and so they did
this basically by delivering one frame
at a time over time because the cast one
inch you always integrate or almost
always integrate at one end of the
repeat spacer array so based on the
order that things are integrated you can
tell when they were introduced and so
they added one frame of this at a time
and were able to put in this gif of this
running galloping horse the sort of
famous image and at the bottom you can
see this is the reconstructed gif based
on the sequencing that they did so it's
not perfect you can see some of the
pixels are kind of missing or black but
it's pretty good and that's a really
interesting field now basically thinking
about how powerful it would be to be
able to store information in DNA in a
living organism and what you could do
with that so there's still lots of
worked out and how much information you
can actually fit so this is a simple
photo or a couple of photos to make a
video but I think it's a really
interesting thing to think about in the
future
so moving on to the next step in CRISPR
immunity that's crispr RNA processing so
maturing that long crispr RNA into the
actual functional units involves taking
a really long RNA and having a specific
cut at defined sites throughout so I'll
just show you so the main protein that
we think about that does this is called
cast six it used to be called cs5 four
so if you ever come across that name
it's just cast six now so what I'm
showing here is basically this RNA
structure before it gets cut and what's
notable about most RNAs and CRISPR
systems is that they actually fold into
these interesting structures so here we
have stem loops or hair pins that's sort
of the most common form that they fold
into and so here you can see the repeats
on either side of the spacer and the
cast six binding sites are noted at the
base of each of those stem loops so
where the arrow is pointing is where
they cut so if you skip ahead here I'm
graying out the parts that get cut off
and I've kept one of the cast sixes here
because this protein actually stays
bound after it cuts and hangs on to the
end of the stem loop at one end so after
cutting at this really specific
structure and sequence you have a mature
form of the RNA that just has a little
bit of a repeat and most importantly a
single spacer in the middle and so
something that's kind of interesting
about this enzyme in particular is that
it recognizes both the structure of the
RNA and its sequence highly specifically
and it binds very very tightly so it
hangs on more than most proteins would
hang on to something and it also has
this one really key residue h 29 this
histidine that we can mutate and
mutating that histidine doesn't
interfere with binding at all so the
proteins still able to grip onto the RNA
really
tightly but it won't cut and what's
interesting is that we can actually
rescue the cleavage reaction by adding
in imidazoles so the amid is alrea
similar to the structure of histidine
it's the same ring and it can actually
play the same role as the amino acid
would just by flowing in that sorry
the hit imidazole so if you basically
have this mutant you can get it to bind
RNA flow in a middle and then it'll cut
and so why is that important so that
means that we have high affinity high
specificity RNA binding and inducible
cleavage so we can have binding and then
have this enzyme cut whenever we want in
in really easily controlled way so how
might someone want to use that the first
example that I'll tell you about is to
identify unknown RNA binding proteins so
you can do a pulldown basically in this
technique so what happens is if you look
at the top of this kind of complicated
diagram you immobilize this the cast six
protein here it's called cs5 four again
by basically sticking it on two beads
and you're using the mutant version that
won't cut so this is just an RNA binding
protein and then you add in a bate RNA
so you put in the binding the stem loop
to that cast six binds very tightly and
you attach some RNA of interest so some
long sequence that you wonder what might
bind to and so and then you take your
cells of interest you lyse them and flow
the lysate over this and anything that's
interested in binding that RNA will
stick on as you can see in the next row
of this diagram and then you can wash
and wash everything off and make sure
you don't have anything non specifically
bound and then what's really cool here
is that you just add in a middle to make
the CS or the cast six protein able to
cut again it cuts the RNA and releases
the the piece of RNA that you're
actually interested in and this cuts
down on background so stuff that might
not specifically just stick on to the
agarose or to the cs5 or even that won't
come down you're just releasing the part
of the RNA you care about and whatever
is attached to it
and then you can do mass spec and see
what's there so that's an interesting
application that people have been doing
for a couple years now but then there's
also another one basically here we go
and you can engineer gene expression in
some interesting ways so what you really
have with cast six is sort of an RNA
restriction enzyme so you can do things
where you add the binding site the
cleavage site force cast six into some
RNA or add it into the DNA that will
then become transcribed into RNA and
trigger processing of that RNA and so
you can come up with these sort of
interesting gene circuits by connecting
things together and then having them get
cut apart after in the art sorry after
they've been transcribed into RNA and
see what happens and so I'm just giving
you some examples here from this one
paper and how they use this so you can
do a lot of interesting engineering and
engineer of complex regulatory systems
in bacteria at least stuffs where they
were doing this so the next part is
interference so this is the step where
cast proteins take this RNA and go
around the cell looking for the bad guy
and then cut it so what happens is
basically so this is sort of a generic
view of what one of these complexes
looks like so in red you have the RNA
and with the unique spacers shown in
green and then in gray is either one
enzyme or a whole complex of proteins
that kind of carry the RNA around and as
I said before you can see here the base
pairing is what actually shows this
enzyme that it's found its target so
when you have complementarity between
the RNA and the DNA the base pairs zip
up and displace one strand of the DNA
and allow the protein to know okay this
is what I was looking for it's time to
cut it so some of these enzymes will cut
just once
some of them will chew a little bit more
and I'll get into that in a second so
there's actually a diversity of what
that gray blob can actually look like
and so on the left here you're seeing
the
ecoli system which is it uses this multi
subunit complex called cascade and that
protein finds targets in double-stranded
DNA and then recruits this additional
nucleus to actually cut the target
called cast 3 in the middle you see the
more simple system or streamlined cast 9
which is pretty well known nowadays and
you can see how it's much smaller than
the other systems and it's just this one
protein that carries out interference
and then on the right there's a little
bit of the type 3 systems so this is
more similar in structure to type 1 and
involves a whole lot of proteins that do
a lot of processing and we've just been
learning recently about some really
interesting interactions where they
actually generate these cyclic
nucleotides to signal to a separate
nucleus to come cut the target in
addition to cutting both RNA and DNA
themselves so those are really
complicated involve a lot of different
cleavage reactions but I thought I would
go through and kind of tell you about
how these work so cascade and cast 3 in
the type 1e system as I said it's a
multi-subunit complex find Silla
stranded DNA and Kreutz separate
nuclease helicase called cast 3 to come
destroy the target cast 9 this is just a
little diagram of where the different
nucleus sites are so cast 9 uses the
guide RNA or single guide RNA shown in
orange to find double-stranded DNA
targets also and then it has these two
nucleus domains H and H and rough C that
are shown as circles in this picture
that each cut one strand of the
double-stranded DNA generating basically
a blunt cut or a double strand break and
then another one that I that wasn't on
the previous slide because that slide
was made before this was even known is
called cast 13a
or C 2 C 2 so again all these proteins
have an original name and then they get
updated so the updated name is cast 13 a
and this is an interesting protein
because it is again a single effector
protein like cast 9 but instead of
cutting double-stranded DNA like most of
these other systems it actually
it's RNA and an interesting thing about
it is that it doesn't just cut the
target that it's bound base-pair to
it'll cut a little bit outside of that
and so it can cut the target that it's
bound to but can also cut any RNA that's
sort of nearby so it's a transacting
artist so what do we get out of this we
have once we got all these enzymes in
our pocket we have precise nucleic acid
recognition and cleavage that we can use
for whatever we want and so what have
people done so you might know the answer
to this one already genome editing
that's the big application here so
mostly people use cast 9 there's also a
protein called CPF one that's more and
more popular I think probably there's
going to be new ones in the next few
years being discovered but for the most
part people use cast 9 if they're just
doing something simple so the way that
this works is they have you use cast 9
or some previous techniques that involve
these protein complexes called talons
and zinc fingers to generate a really
specific cut in DNA generating a
double-stranded break so in the natural
system this would be a way to stop viral
infection so your target would be about
the viral genome but if you put these
into eukaryotes or any other system
really that you want you can generate
targeted breaks in the eukaryotic genome
so once you have a double-stranded break
the CRISPR systems job is over and now
it's the machinery of the cell the host
machinery that repairs the break in
different ways so there's basically two
ways that this can go down in one case
this is sort of the desperate haphazard
solution where the cell just slaps these
ends back together and it can do that
correctly so sometimes it just zips them
right back together but sometimes it'll
do it kind of wrong so it's instead of
just zipping it back together it'll
connect different pieces and then
whatever's in the middle will get kind
of chopped out or it'll insert some
random stuff but it's still closing the
gap and so you can imagine that adding
something random or deleting something
at the site making an endo and it's
insertion or deletion
would mess up a gene if this were in the
middle of a coding sequence it probably
wouldn't work after you've screwed up
the interior so this is a great way of
knocking out cheese the other thing you
can do is try to integrate new DNA so
basically if you have so this is
something that's useful like if you have
an unhealthy mutation in a gene in a
person people are hopeful that we can
actually use this technology to cut at
the place where that mutation is present
and swap in DNA that contains the
healthy version of the gene and we do
this by designing the ends of the DNA to
look similar to the ends of the break so
the cell thinks what was here I don't
know
this DNA has some similar sequences this
is probably what was in the middle I'll
just slap that back in and patch over
this gap and so that's a little bit less
efficient and right now that's kind of
one of the limiting factors and what we
can do with gene editing therapeutically
but it still happens sometimes so we're
kind of I mean especially at the IGI
we're working on trying to improve how
efficient that process is and how we can
control what the cell does after we make
the cut so basically what you can do
using these proteins is to knock out
genes or knock in genes and this slide
is here just to show you that people
have already been using this a lot it
was only really discovered in 2012-2013
and developed around that time and
already just in the past five four or
five years people have done gene editing
and all of the different organisms on
the screen right here and this is
actually just a subset it's actually way
more than that but this is really great
because as you can see in these purplish
highlights these are classic model
organisms so these were sort of the
systems that people were able to
manipulate genetically and study for the
past I don't know 50 hundred years with
relative ease but now we're not really
just limited to those systems we can do
gene editing and do experiments and all
these other organisms so microbes plants
animals insects it's really interesting
so it's really opened up a whole lot of
different avenues for research and then
of course there are a ton of clinical
uses that people would love to develop
as well as agricultural applications
there's a lot I'm sure you can read all
about it on our website if you're
interested to learn more about what
people are trying to do another
interesting aspect that is kind of less
discussed but very powerful is not gene
editing but gene manipulation so instead
of cutting the genome and trying to
remove something or adding something in
you can kind of do more fine-tuned
control of gene expression so what I'm
showing here is on the left you can see
cuts and Nick's and stuff but on in the
middle and on the right it's showing
that you can really use caste 9 or
another one of these RNA guided
nucleases just as a DNA recruitment a
site specific DNA recruitment tool so
you can bring other proteins by
tethering them to the caste 9 to a
specific site in DNA and all you have to
do is mutate the nucleus domains of the
caste 9 protein so that doesn't cut the
target anymore but still binds so you
can do a lot of interesting stuff here
you can bring fluorescent proteins to
visualize a different place in DNA you
can bring activators or repressors to
turn genes on and off and people have
been using this largely in a screen
format so that you can do these sort of
massively parallel experiments seeing if
I turn on a gene in all these different
sorry if I turn on lots of different
genes simultaneously or turn off a bunch
of different genes what happens and you
can see you know in a given cell you're
old enough or on one gene at a time but
you can do all these experiments in
parallel and get a ton of different
information about a given process that
you're interested in so that's called
CRISPR I or CRISPR a screening which
again you can read more about so the
last application within interference
that I was going to talk about is viral
diagnostics
so this again you can see with all the
citations in the corner this is all
happening in the past couple years it's
really quick but what's interesting here
is that people use this cast 13a protein
as a sentinel so marking detecting RNA
and really sensitive to with a really
sensitive threshold so what the way it
works is that basically you have a you
design your crisper RNA to target some
sort of RNA of interest so maybe it's
something from dengue or Zika virus
that's what's been used so far in
experiments and so you make it so the
RNA will bind to that DNA or RNA but
then you also add in this marker or
signaling RNA that has a fluorophore
that's quenched so when it's not cut
these two things close together mean no
fluorescence but when it's activated by
binding to the viral RNA that it's
detecting it cuts elsewhere as I said
before in trans and cuts the the
quenched fluorophore so when that gets
cut the fluorophore becomes fluorescent
because it's no longer quenched and you
see a signal so you basically have an
RNA detection event that induces a
bright signal and so this recently was
sort of optimized using this Sherlock
system and shown that they could detect
really really small amounts of RNA and
actually they introduced ways of doing
this to detect DNA as well and what's
really interesting that I'll highlight
here is that you don't often see this a
and when you're looking at binding
curves or fluorescence and this is this
means add a molar so Adam Oller
sensitivity that's the amount of RNA
that needs to be there for this to work
which is very very small so this is a
really interesting way that we could
potentially develop chips or devices to
take someone's blood or urine or some
sort of bodily fluid and then just put
it somewhere and see this fluorescent
signal if there is a certain virus and
detectable in their in their body so you
could use this for dengue or Zika as I
said or other targets it's kind of
you know it could be adaptable to a lot
of things so this could be a really
powerful tool and then I forgot I
included this sorry so that the next the
final one this is actually the final one
is targeted anti microbials so in the
bottom left you can see a diagram
showing a bacteriophage actually
injecting a CRISPR system in a in an
ironic turn of events
and if you design this CRISPR system to
target the bacterial genome and cut it
that actually kills the bacterium so in
eukaryotes we have these sophisticated
four pair systems that let us cut gaps
and or sorry fix gaps in DNA but in
bacteria they just die so you could
imagine that it would be powerful to
have a targeted version a targeted
system for killing bacteria of different
strains and what you might use this for
which I'm showing in this diagram is to
eliminate really specific strains of
bacteria within a community so if you
have a pathogenic strain in your gut for
example but and you want to wipe it out
this is a way that you could overcome
having having to use antibiotics or to
kill bacteria that are resistant to
antibiotics and you should not kill any
of the host cells so the human cells
won't get hurt at all
because the bacteria phage will only
infect bacteria and you should really
only cut the targeted area so you design
the guide RNA to only target some
sequence that's unique to the strain
that you're trying to destroy and so you
can selectively eliminate pathogens or
other and undesirable bacteria from the
community this way and this hasn't this
has worked so far sort of an experiments
but as far as I know no one has done
this in a person yet but there's a lot
of interests in this area that's just
sort of starting and there's a bunch of
different companies that have been
cropping up to pursue this so this
brings me to the last step and anti
crispers so this is the phage response
to CRISPR systems so what they've
basically evolved are these tiny little
proteins that just wedge into
existing cast proteins and stop them
from working so you can see in this
diagram this is a different version
basically of the CRISPR pathway slide
that I've been showing you and you can
see on the left and right there are
these inhibition lines showing you each
step of the CRISPR system and which anti
CRISPR protein or AC our protein has
evolved to inhibit that step so as you
can see most of the steps have some sort
of protein that's evolved to inhibit
them and we've really only been studying
these for a few years so I imagine there
are way more anti CRISPR proteins out
there that we just don't even know about
yet that probably inhibit some of the
steps that don't have one marked right
now so what's useful about the earth I
guess I'll show you how this works in a
little bit of detail so in the type 1
systems as I said there are these multi
subunit complexes that all assemble
around a guide RNA and here you're
seeing these two copies of the red anti
CRISPR protein and one copy of the green
one and they just stick to different
sites along this complex and they can
all bind at once and they all work in
sort of different ways which is really
interesting here's another one that
works as a dimer to inhibit the caste 3
nucleus helicase that would be recruited
by one of the type one targeting
complexes and then more recently we've
found ones for type 2 systems so these
can stop cast nine and other proteins
from working in different ways so they
can sometimes inhibit the cleavage step
or inhibit the binding step it depends
on the anti CRISPR so what we have here
is specific cast protein inhibition
that's the ability that we have how
might we use that recently people have
been using this as an off switch for
cast nine so here you're seeing that in
this case the inhibitor when you add it
in red it's shown in red and it will
block DNA binding by cast nine and so
what you can use this for is diminishing
off target effects in genome editing so
sometimes the cast nine protein will cut
where you want it to when you're doing a
gene editing experiment but sometimes it
cuts at places that are just sort of
similar so the sequence is off by a
couple of nucleotides but
the enzyme is not sensitive enough to
detect the difference that it cuts there
anyway and so this is a problem just to
some extent if we're trying to develop
human therapeutics because you wouldn't
want to put a protein inside of you
that's going to cause random cuts at
places you don't want and maybe cause
cancer so controlling off targets has
been a really big area of research
recently and so in this paper that I'm
referencing right here they showed that
if you time the delivery of an anti
CRISPR protein just a little bit after
you had the cast 9 introduced to the
cells you're able to retain the on
target cuts that you want while
diminishing the off target ones and the
thinking is that you put cast 9 in it
kind of quickly goes and does the cut
that you want but then it's still
floating around the cell and has nothing
else to do but look for more targets and
that's giving it a chance to cut at the
wrong place so if you add it first give
it a chance to do what you want then
blow in this anti CRISPR protein it'll
cut down on the off targets well letting
the initial edit happen okay so I'm just
gonna review basically what I've told
you and so this is the CRISPR pathway
again now we've seen how each of these
steps works and then how it's also been
co-opted for lots of different
applications so you can see here these
are the different abilities that the
CRISPR system has so during the first
step of spacer acquisition it's doing
really site specific DNA integration
next it has during the CRISPR and a
maturation step you have this really
high affinity RNA binding and cleavage
reaction that happens to make the mature
CRISPR RNAs and then in the last step of
interference that requires precise RNA
or DNA binding and cleavage and then as
I added the anti CRISPR proteins encoded
by phage can inactivate the cast
proteins to overcome the CRISPR system
and so if you switch here all these
little abilities that the systems
naturally have have been co-opted for
all these different applications that
are really powerful and interesting so
you can do DNA based information storage
RNA pull-downs and synthetic
biology genome manipulation viral
diagnosis antimicrobial systems and then
off switches for gene editing which
could be useful also in gene drives
which I didn't really talk about but in
mostly reducing off target effects okay
so with that I will just give a
shout-out or acknowledgement to the IGI
my employer so as I said this is a
Berkeley UCSF effort that's hoping to
advance Genome Research share reagents
let people that are working on similar
problems work together fostering
collaborations in the Bay Area and
Beyond and then also putting a big
emphasis on education and outreach and
providing resources to people that are
really curious about these processes and
just need a little bit of guidance and
explanation and then finally ethics is
kind of a big deal and the CRISPR world
if you want to watch Jennifer Doudna TED
talk and the bottom right she talks
about this a lot being able to
manipulate genomes has some potentially
scary uses in addition to all the really
wonderful therapeutic uses we're trying
to develop so it's it's important to
talk about these things now before the
technology is already at the place where
we can start doing them so yeah if you
go to our web site you can learn more
there are a lot of other ways so there's
our website there's social media if you
want to follow me on Twitter or the IGI
account our handles are here and I find
the hashtag CRISPR to be really useful
on Twitter to follow all the news
because there's so much coming out in
this field every day YouTube has a lot
of cool videos there's really a lot of
resources available to you if you want
to learn more about this and of course
I'll answer questions in the Q&A if you
have more specific questions about the
talk okay so that's it thank you
Thank You dr. Hopp Strasser for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for if we are unable to get
to your question we will follow up with
you and via email after the presentation
let's get started our first question is
do you know of ways that bacteria can
overcome antique whispers
okay so the question is are there ways
of bacteria overcome anti CRISPR
proteins so this is something that I get
asked a lot and I think most of the
people that work on anti CRISPR Persians
get asked this a lot so you think if
anti crispers just totally overcome
CRISPR systems why do we even have
CRISPR systems how our bacteriophage not
just winning the war and getting rid of
bacteria and I think so far we're not
really sure about this I think a lot of
people wonder if there are anti anti
crispers out there and I'm not sure I
hope people figure it out soon I think
this is probably an area of research for
a lot of people and there's a lot of
interest right now and how what the
bacterial responses to the anti CRISPR
development and how the war has
continued because it's always
ping-ponging back and forth once one
side develops some sort of defense the
other side finds a way to overcome it so
I think that war is continuing and maybe
the anti anti crispers will also be
really important biotechnology tools it
remains to be seen
and we'll wrap up with one more question
and that question is what is the status
of the various potential clinical uses
of CRISPR genome editing so where do we
stand on clinical uses of CRISPR there's
tons and tons of interest lots of
different labs are working on various
ways to use CRISPR to combat disease and
people so far the only clinical trials
that have been initiated are to look at
cancer therapies so actually it's kind
of a timely moment so yesterday the FDA
just approved the first car T cell
therapy to combat cancer from Novartis
and that's a technique that people are
trying to incorporate CRISPR into so you
have to engineer basically how that
works is you take t-cells out of people
someone with cancer and then engineer
them to be better at killing tumors and
you could use CRISPR for the engineering
step and then you put the cells back
into the person and hope that they'll
they'll be able to find the tumors and
destroy them and so yeah people are
trying to use CRISPR for this not quite
I don't think that one of the trials
maybe use cart T cells but a lot of them
are a kind of slightly different
approach but still engineering T cells
for cancer I think there might be one or
two additional newer trials coming out
sort of similar uses but a lot of the
efforts are sort of right at the
precipice of getting started so there's
a lot of people doing preclinical work
that are going to start clinical trials
in the next one to three years or so and
I think we can expect to see some of
those starting pretty soon I think yes
so far there's nothing really up and
running for treating genetic disease so
that's the main thing that people are
excited about it I think for the most
part with crispers that you could
potentially correct underlying defects
in people's DNA that is causing disease
for that
and do it permanently so it could
potentially be a cure if you can
actually get these gene editing reagents
to the part of the body they need to be
in and successfully tweak the DNA you
could completely stop whatever the
disease is permanently because your DNA
shouldn't be changing otherwise so
applications like that could be used for
these diseases that we've understood for
a really really long time but not been
able to treat at all beyond treating the
symptoms so that would include things
like sickle cell disease and cystic
fibrosis Huntington's disease tay-sachs
all kinds of things that have these
really well understood mutations that
lead to the pathology they all have
potential they're all potentially
treated using CRISPR but we're kind of
almost there not quite there there's
still a few things that need to be
overcome which is a kind of longer
question but I think where you can
expect some really interesting stuff to
come out in the next couple years
I would like to once again thank dr.
Hawk Strasser for her presentation do
you have any final comments I would just
say thanks for listening if you have
more questions I can probably respond to
them over time dad I hope you enjoyed
the presentation and stay tuned for all
the CRISPR research that's yet to come
thank you once again dr. Hawke Strasser
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 14 2017 you will
receive an email from LaBrie letting you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye